[Music]
nearly every fps game out there has a
weapon or two
that is just busted some of them get
patched before players are even really
able to abuse them while others manage
to survive
long enough to terrorize you in
matchmaking for
months so this week we wanted to take a
look at the guns that make you want to
pull your hair out the guns that even
your average scrub
can slay with but before we get into
that make sure you are subscribed to the
score esports and that way you'll never
miss a video
just like this one and with that let's
get into the top 10 broken guns
in gaming
kicking off our list we've got balarance
operator
if he would have been my friend but now
immortals after that last one
are you choking me his tongue is real
they know they're collateral immortals
what what can they even do they make
their way on site
no and everything tends with an ace
at ballerin's launch the op was insane
just about
every top player was interlocking jet
and just
dominating every game with this gun i
used to i was so confident with the off
when uh
prior to like the nerf and like uh the
fire rate was
faster like i actually felt so confident
just going for aggressive peak after
aggressive peak
i just like peaking constantly the
combination of the extreme
firepower affordable four and a half
thousand credit cost and jets mobility
meant that players could just keep
repeating angles over and over again
now riot did eventually nerf the op
raising the price to a whopping 5 000
credits while lowering the firing rate
significantly these changes scared
players away from the weapon for a
little while but a recent update saw the
price reduced to 4
700 so who knows maybe we'll be seeing
more of the operator
very soon the blazer not going to find
anything just yet i see looking for
something 80s
down through the halls koala finds the
first spike down needs to be retrieved
but the toxic screen should allow for
that
and i possibly can oh my god the
collateral
what was that shot mimi
coming in at at number nine spot we have
the most overpowered [ __ ] to ever
grace a call of duty
game the akimbo model 1887's from modern
warfare 2.
for a shotgun that had the range of a
[ __ ] ballistic missile the 1887 and
its name isn't for the year it was
invented but the range it can shoot
shells and miles
with insane range absolutely unfair
damage and
crazy accuracy these shotguns combined
with certain perks
terrorized just about every cod player
when the game first came out
now luckily infinity ward eventually
nerfed the ridiculous range of the model
but the damage was already done
and people are pretty pissed to this day
imagine a sniper in the game which can
shoot eight bullets at a time
you'd say that's a pretty [ __ ] stupid
idea infinity ward it's about as
balanced as your daft or ten pints
in our number eight spot we have a gun
that tilted cs go players into
oblivion the org the orc has long been
looked down on by hardcore cs go fans
but in a february 2014 update val
decided to buff the weapon by increasing
the rate of fire and giving it more
scoped control
in return we got what would later be
known as orbweak
after a week of hell the org was finally
nerfed
the new 3 300 price tag was a little
rich for most players wallets but when
the price was dropped to
fifty 3150 in an october 2018 update
things got really out of hand the
rotation over towards the
bombsite but elise he he should be able
to get two or three
depending on where they go and you can
see it's been so long hasn't it's day
seven and they still don't know that
he's one
of one of them and they're gonna line up
oh my god they all it comes through
beautifully
triple for him and he's gonna close it
out a wonderful ace here from elise it
took a few months for team to realize
the org's full potential and although
some players thought it was just a noob
weapon
others dominated with it hell ants even
managed to make it to the grand finals
of a major
in part thanks to the so-called cod gun
eventually the orgs price was reverted
back to its original 3
300 but given it's still the same
powerhouse
some players are still sticking with it
strafing into our number seven spot now
we have yet another new
friendly weapon the spitfire
jesus
oh dude i don't know bro that's why it's
good though
that's right there apex players have
been complaining about this gun
on and off basically since the game came
out the large magazine capacity
and tight hip fire spread make it an
absolute nightmare to play against
this gun is so [ __ ] crazy now
although the spitfire has been nerfed a
few times
some players still think it's just
busted in the proper hands this weapon
can be
terrifying
slaying its way into the number six spot
we have ella's scorpion from rainbow six
siege
when ella was released alongside legion
and ying in august 2017
players quickly realized that her gun
the scorpion was
way too overpowered with a 50 bullet
magazine
one of the highest fire rates in the
game and virtually
zero recoil pretty much everyone was
locking in
ella and getting in on the fun it's all
up to kanto he sees julio and he'll take
him down
so now it's a 2v1 essentially kamikaze
he sees pcd
kanto are you kidding me it's just
kamikaze left
and now kanto's gonna wait out the time
they can't do it in time kanto
wanted just to clutch that round out and
end three in a row the mag size has been
nerfed
only 40 bullets and the recoil is now
much harder to control
but regardless ella's scorpion has given
us some pretty iconic clips over the
years
if you can see psycho he's got that top
west side control and he's going to
continue to try and clear out these
roamers but it's just continuing to
stall
cancer kenny the first kill of this
series the second kill
of this year the third kill of this
series
bursting its way into our number five
spot is valorance classic
despite literally being free this pistol
has been one of the most ridiculous
weapons in the game
since launch the right click burst
allows players to hit their opponents
with ease even while jumping
despite being nerfed a couple of times
in the past year some players are still
begging right to remove the burst
feature altogether
but until the devs finally listen we'll
continue to see plenty
of extremely skilled plays with this
pistol
one enemy remaining oh my god spike down
i went for another right click because i
was just feeling it
in our number four spot now we have the
wingman from apex legends
minus 40 on that guy
basically since the game first came out
people have been debating whether or not
the wingman is
just busted the core issue with the gun
is that with the skill piercer
attachment
players can one shot their opponents in
the head from pretty much any range
the issue is that the wingman is a
pistol so
while some might say that it simply
rewards good aim playing against
somebody who can kill you from across
the map with a pistol
still feels pretty bad
one more on me he's dead
scoping its way into the number three
spot is the sg
552 or as most people refer to it the
krieg
the retake scenario for atk oh
okay and a decent fade away shot to
start jk
he's back once again four kills he just
got everyone in a matter of seconds
much like the org the krieg was always
powerful but a
price drop got everyone to realize just
how good it could be
with the best first shot accuracy in the
game a high rate of fire and a short
reload time
mccree basically dominated cs go for an
entire
year five kills overall and him three of
them in this round
what kind of money can i be oh that's a
beautiful shot wow
that's liaz hitting the dirt
oh another one the follow up from rpk a
one
versus two and he's got a real chance
that would be huge the monotone is going
to limit his space down here but now
he's out in the open
he just wants to continue on that one
shot head shot situation and
he actually falls back here they're
going to line up for him he gets one oh
my god
the one versus four valve finally nerfed
this weapon in april 2020
and since then basically everyone has
gone back to their beloved ak's
in our runner-up spot we have the most
broken weapon in all of valorant
the judge or he can use his brain and
beat his team around
but uh nonetheless
the judge is probably the best gun in
the entire game despite being an auto
shotgun the range on this thing
is absolutely mental and it basically
requires no skill to use
back in march a controller-wielding
cipher main named daznerth
even managed to hit rank 22 on the north
american leaderboards
using nothing but the judge now that's
not proof that this thing is busted i
don't know what is
yeah they're gonna invest all right
riot recently raised the price of the
judge from 1600 credits to 1850 and
nerfed its damage fall off but that
hasn't stopped players from abusing this
broken ass shotgun
being able to defuse sentinels win a
fifth by the skin of their teeth
and what is tens doing running a blog
getting free
in our top spot we have the undisputed
most broken gun in all of counter strike
the r8 revolver somebody
you get one shot somebody with a [ __ ]
pistol
why is that allowed
oh my god this gun's insane added as a
part of a december 2015
update the ra instantly became the best
gun in the game
this thing was a pocket orb with insane
range
damage accuracy and killing power there
was pretty much
no point buying any rifles let alone an
orb it has the same damage output as the
op except there is a decay in damage
over distance
it doesn't have to scope and cost a
fraction of the ops price
it's basically a hand op thankfully
valve nerfed the revolver a week later
by lowering the damage output and
increasing the time between
shots but still to this day nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they were thinking with
this one
give me that
well there you have it that was a list
of what we think
are the most broken guns in gaming are
there any others out there that are more
broken that we
really should have put on the list let
us know thanks for watching and i'll see
you all in the next one
it killed me
i hit him